Yo digo que los negros me trataron mejor
que los judíos
¿Quién quiere que diga más?
Primero Dios
Usted...
¿Por qué usted contribuye? ¿A usted le gusta contribuir en las instituciones judías?
No sé
Pregúntale a Sam
te va a decir
que estuvo en el viaje con nosotros
Jefe de viaje
Mamá conoce a él muy bien
Usted pregúntale
¿Usted cree que la Shoá le ha afectado su forma de ver la vida?
¿La Shoá?
¿Haber pasado por el holocausto?
¿Le afectó su forma de ver la vida?
No me hizo nada de afecto
Y de afecto dice que me dio mi Señor
Por eso yo digo
que yo no sé de qué yo estoy construido
¿Pero le afectó haber pasado por esta guerra?
Nada, un hilo no
Sí, ahorita mire
tapados los hijos
Honduras perdió el 95%, mire
es sobre todo de Venecia
no allá, acá
de Venezuela
esto va a tener un 95% perdido
Ya, me oye muy bien, gracias a Dios me defienden
¿Usted me ha pedido todo?
Mire, señor Isaac
¿Y tuvo otros hijos? ¿Tuvo entonces cuantos hijos usted con su esposa?
Tres hijas
¿Cómo se llaman?
Gisela Rayo de Lerna
Anita
Rays
¿Sabes para qué Rays?
Gisela Rayo de Lerna
y su nieta
de Malca
¿Qué me puede decir de Ana?
Dígame algo de su hija mayor
Yo sufrí mucho
por la hija mía mayor, mucho
Usted no me imagina
lo callado
Noches que yo no estoy durmiendo
y no puedo llorar nada
materialmente sí
lo demás usted sabe, no puedo llorar
pero Dios dice así
tú haga y Dios te ayuda
un solo quien ayudas y Dios te ayuda
¿Y qué piensa de ella?
como persona, como hija
Mire, yo quiero decirte una cosa
oye bien
cuando yo caminaba con mi hermano en el bosque
yo dije, mire, cuando yo estoy en libertad
yo puedo pensar
qué puedo hacer
también soy castigado
estoy en libertad
estoy materialmente bien
y no puedo ayudar nada
cada uno es un mundo
¿Y de su hija Gisela qué me puede decir?
Es una hija ejemplar
que no hay palabras
su nieta es una hija ejemplar
yo tengo seis nietos
usted conozca
ejemplar, que yo estoy orgulloso
tengo dos yernos
que no hay palabras
nunca
en el tiempo que vimos
no han faltado
una palabra, no me faltaba
cada uno dice tonterías
como
y dicen en ruso, estaré cal de ti, un viejo es como un niño, ¿no?
puedo decir unas cosas
oye, y no
dicen, papá, tú hiciste malo
no te diga, no te diga
cabez
of
es lo primero que dice la Torah
¿Usted piensa en la guerra frecuentemente?
no, nunca no me olvido, callado
no estoy hablando
¿Qué pregunta más?
¿Usted cree que la crianza
que por sus experiencias usted influenció la crianza de sus hijas?
o sea, por haber pasado por todo esto
las sus hijas tuvieron una crianza diferente a otros niños
no capto
¿Usted cree que por haber pasado por esto
sus hijas tuvieron una crianza diferente a otros niños?
¿Usted les dio otras?
yo quiero tener una cosa, mire, que mis
hijas no tenían esto que tenían otros hijos, ¿por qué?
por yo
estaba muy reservado
aquí en tiempo que yo estuve acá, mire, yo tenía que luchar
muy duro, luchar por la vida
otros padres sí podían dar mucho lujo a sus hijos
y yo no podía dar lujos
no, y digo una cosa, mire
lujo que va a dar usted
con ayuda de Dios
lindos matrimonios
y que Dios ayude a usted
esposos con toda suerte
esa era mi ayuda
no gozaban como las hijas
y gozaban
no, gracias a Dios
que ahorita tienen bien buenos esposos
y pueden gozar de la vida
y yo estoy muy feliz
y estoy feliz
que todo lo que ya pasó
ya usted sabe
que puedo hablar con todo el mundo
entiendo a todo el mundo
y mis hijos hasta hoy
no me faltaron respeto
mis nietos no me faltaron respeto
y dan más
que caber hoy
usted
haber pasado por el holocausto, la Shoah
¿le cambió la forma de ver el judaísmo?
nada, hoy mismo
una cosa
sí me cambió
en esos 50 años
no estudiaba Talmud
pero estudiar Talmud
necesita un cerebro muy limpio
y tranquilidad
tranquilidad
no tengo
se ha vuelto ya
¿cuál pregunta más?
¿algún mensaje que usted quiera dar para el Señor?
este mensaje yo doy
cuando paramos en la mesa
poco a parados
dígalas por favor
yo quiero que están de presente mis hijas
ya pueden venir
entonces vamos con las fotos
y luego vamos con la familia